you believe he has you honestly believe
that he has a didi well I I think if you
watch him even and particularly if you
read the transcripts to some of the
interviews you know he's done them with
the New York Times and The Wall Street
Journal if you asked him a question
about Saudi Arabia say you know 30
seconds into it he goes into Iowa
farmers and why they voted for him and
then he goes to Justin Trudeau and why
Trudeau actually loves him and then he
goes from there to to our Bayon to Japan
and to trade policy and it's like two
minutes later you're literally you've
just circumnavigated the globe yeah and
so yeah I'm you know I'm not a medical
doctor but it just seemed like he is
very it's very difficult for him to
stick with one subject yeah he's like
those little automatic things at the
bottom of a pool that vacuum it and they
just wander you know they're just
wandering there's no malice they're just
they're in your head you know you're
having your drink and your head looking
at it
you know I've heard of a lot of
metaphors for Donald Trump but the
Polaris pool cleaner is a new one yeah
did you just gave the brand name right
wife maybe it's one of the brand yeah
you're trying to get a free cool plane
all right didn't you see I didn't
mention the brand but you're I'm very
smart you're like hahaha
the Polaris
matt'll turned out they don't even make
food they don't make some no probably
not
you